Is it okay to punch a Nazi?
I mean we did go to war against them, so yeah.
This week's top story: If you see a Nazi,
punch a Nazi.
Liberals should not be raving about this.
A new segment we like to call fuck up a Nazi.
My 90 year uncle, if he was alive would have
punched that son of a bitch in the face
and I woulda had his back.
It was a hotly debated question for months
after video of white nationalist Richard Spencer
getting punched in the middle of an interview
on the day of Donald Trump's inauguration
went viral and inspired countless remixes.
But the question was never really just about
Nazis
it was about the acceptability of political
violence.
And in the following year, the question came
up again and again
as several high profile political protests turned violent.
Including one on the campus of UC Berkeley.
We visited Berkeley about a year after that
protest turned riot
to ask students whether punching Nazis, or
other deplorables is ever okay.
If they want to punch a Nazi, I'm not going
to judge.
It depends on what you define as a Nazi.
The people whose words create a culture that
sort of ratifies violence against a certain group
are punchable.
On February 1st 2017 the nation watched the
University of California Berkeley burn
as masked members of the far left group Antifa
lit fires,
threw safety barriers through store windows
physically attacked people and threw rocks
at police.
The protests turned riots were sparked by
the arrival of right wing provocateur
Milo Yiannopoulos
invited to campus by a conservative student
group.
President Trump helped ignite the controversy
by tweeting a threat
to pull federal funding from Berkeley.
Protests continued throughout the rest of
the year
as more conservative speakers were drawn to
the Berkeley campus.
The students we talked to said that the violence
was carried out almost entirely by outsiders.
A lot of outside media comes in and sees,
you know, something very sensational
like stuff on fire in the middle of Sprout
Plaza where we're standing
and takes this to represent that young people
are not interested in civil discourse
which is not true.
Specifically if you go back to the Milo riots,
one of the things that really annoys me about
all of this,
is that Berkeley students are blamed for all
of the damage that happened to our campus.
There's just a small group of, like, people,
Antifa you've probably heard of them
and they just come up here, mess everything
up, we get blamed for it
and then all the students are just like 'aww
that sucks.'
Antifa, short for anti-fascist, is a decentralized
movement that rejects the tactic of non-violence
and vows to fight whatever or whomever it
identifies as fascist by any means necessary.
They are taking advantage of the Berkeley
campus
and the Berkeley students and the Berkeley people
and we're getting a rap for something that's
not associated necessarily with us.
Pretty much resorting to this force, this
violence,
pepper spraying just Trump supporters
who did nothing other than express their political opinions
that's not what we should be doing at all.
And I want to say that that's not what Antifa
should be doing either.
Most of the students we spoke to condemned
the group and it's tactics.
But they were also reluctant to condemn political
violence altogether.
I personally wouldn't throw a stone through
a window
but I would never criticize the psyche of
someone who does.
I think it's hard for there to be very big
change without some sort of violent aspect to it
whether that's property destruction or human
life which is like the sad reality that we live in.
That speech can be considered violence, inviting
people like Milo Yiannopoulos
creates an unsafe environment for the people
that he is speaking against.
Property damage is absolutely justifiable.
Dr Martin Luther King Jr. once said that riots
are the language of the voiceless.
To kind of hearken back to what MLK said,
a way for the unheard to make their voices amplified.
A riot is the language of the unheard.
That famous quote has been widely misinterpreted.
King wasn't condoning riots,
he was saying that in response to racial oppression,
it was understandable, though counterproductive.
And that nonviolent protest is the only path
to social change.
I think for the negro to turn to violence
would be both impractical and immoral.
Putting aside the question of whether or not
preemptive political violence is moral,
is it actually effective?
In 'Why Civil Resistance Works' political
scientists Erica Chenoweth and Maria Stephan
compared violent and non violent movements
throughout history
and found that non violent ones were more
than twice as effective at achieving their goals.
Princeton researcher Omar Wasow
found that the non violent protests of the
early civil rights movement changed minds
while the left wing riots in the late 1960s
likely tipped the presidential election in
favor of Richard Nixon.
And if Antifa members still want to punch
so called Nazis,
they should pay attention to the work of historian
Laurie Marhoefer
who studies real Nazis and says the party
often rallied close to it's adversaries
in order to provoke them.
Drawing a violent reaction that swayed public
opinion in its favor.
Today's provocateurs are nothing like Adolf
Hitler,
but there's no doubt that Milo Yiannopoulos
chooses to come to places like Berkeley for
a reason.
You hear it a lot, that you're intentionally
trying to provoke
the kind of response we saw last night.
I mean, what my response is 'so what? who
cares?'
I'm an entertainer, I'm a performer.
I personally think that the Milo protest caught
on so much fire
because of the sheer intensity of the people
protesting against him.
It sounds like you're saying the best way
to deal with someone like Milo is to ignore him.
Well that's what you do with trolls, right?
Don't feed the trolls?
Don't feed the trolls!
We got played.
The response to the assault on Richard Spencer
was hardly the only instance of a blase media
response to violence.
The brutal attack on Senator Rand Paul, which
left him with bruised lungs and six broken ribs
was met with jokes and suggestions that he
had it coming
because of his libertarian views.
Is it justifiable to act violently towards
someone who comes to campus
and is advocating against universal health
care?
I don't think I'd punch that person, yeah.
Is it okay for someone else to?
I wouldn't encourage it.
If it happened I don't know that I would feel
any particular remorse.
But you don't have to feel remorse for what
happens to your political opponents
to condemn violence against them.
Because punching them will most likely further
their cause.
The right of protest is a crucial one that
deserves protection.
But it's vital that anyone seeking political
change seriously consider these questions.
Is political violence morally justifiable?
And if so, is it really worth it?
If we say that it's okay to punch a Nazi,
do we risk that umbrella of who's a Nazi becoming
a little too large?
No.